CARTER MORGAN: Hi,
I'm Carter Morgan,
and today I'll be talking to
you about API-first application
development.
Whether you're
adopting cloud services
or transitioning to a
cloud infrastructure,
an API-first approach can
help you manage the complexity
enveloping new applications.
Let's check out how.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
As organizations
are increasingly
leveraging cloud technologies
to build applications,
they implement processes to
orchestrate new microservices
architectures, containerization,
and continuous delivery.
But where do they
even start when
developing a new application?
As the first step,
they need to make sure
that the data that will be
powering the application
is exposed as an API.
The developers responsible for
the rest of the application
will be the first
consumers of this API.
This ensures that
the application
has the quality,
predictability, and stability
to withstand web clients, mobile
users, and other developer
consumers.
But although APIs help
you unlock innovation,
in order to accelerate
it, organizations
need to rethink their workforce
to expand their application
development bandwidth.
Their traditional
code-first approach
to application
development sometimes
results in delays, rework,
or disjointed experiences
for end users.
Additionally there is
a large growing deficit
of developers in the world.
And as a result,
IT organizations
are experiencing a huge
backlog of software requests,
slow development cycles,
and security challenges.
Because of this,
organizations are
adopting no-code application
development solutions along
with an API-first approach to
empower their line of business
workers to build applications
within the guardrails
prescribed by IT.
Why, you may ask?
Well, there are several benefits
for choosing this approach.
First, by decoupling
internal independencies
from the back end
to the front end,
work can progress faster
and independently.
Next, by showing only
the necessary details
to the intended
users via APIs, we
hide the complexity
of connecting
to data and services.
And lastly, leveraging
a no-code approach
allows companies to quickly
create high-fidelity prototypes
and gather feedback for
end users and iterate.
Now, let's talk a little bit
about how you can leverage APIs
to build applications
without coding
using Apigee and AppSheet.
You can easily connect
to existing Apigee APIs
within Apigee,
customize applications,
and deploy to mobile web
and desktop interfaces
with the click of a button.
This shortens development
timelines considerably.
Let's look at a quick
demo of how this works.
We're going to start in the
Apigee environment, where
we have an open API
specification, an API
proxy that represents that
spec, and an API product which
publishes the API proxy for
client applications to consume.
Today, an app created in
AppSheet will be our client.
In our Hipster
products API proxy,
we can see a preflow policy
that checks for an API key.
This helps to secure
the API, as only
apps that have this secret
key it can invoke the API.
Next, we can see
the API product that
publishes the API for
client applications
to use called Hipster Silver.
At the bottom of the
API product definition,
we can see that an app has
been registered already
for AppSheet.
And this is where we get
the API key for our app.
Now we're going to
switch personas.
We've been an Apigee API
producer up until now.
In AppSheet, we
will put on the hat
of the line of business user.
The first thing we'll do
is create a data source
to point to our API in Apigee.
We'll click on + data
source to add a new one.
We will name the data
source Apigee Hipsters Demo
and select the Apigee type.
We enter the API key
from Apigee and the URL
to the OpenAPI Spec.
And now we can validate
and then authorize access
to create the data source.
Next, we can create an app.
We will go to the My Apps area.
AppSheet noticed that we
don't have any apps yet,
so it's assuming we
want to create one.
We do.
We'll use the Start from
Your Own Data Option,
and the data will come
from our Apigee API.
We'll call this
app Hipsters App.
Now is when we get to choose the
Apigee data source we created.
I'll select Apigee
Hipsters Demo.
Let's select Products.
AppSheet just created
the app for us.
And we can see the preview
of the app in the pane
on the right already.
We need to just make
a few adjustments.
I know that there's a picture
of each product in the data,
but it's not showing up.
We'll change the picture
data type to Image.
The product ID is kind of ugly.
Let's change that
app to not show that,
and then it will show
the product name first.
Let's save our changes.
Now the images are showing
up and the product names
look great.
AppSheet helped us create our
first app within a minute.
This is how you
can easily leverage
Apigee API to build no-code
applications with AppSheet.
In summary, the Apigee
data source for AppSheet
gives you an easy way to
leverage your existing APIs
to develop no-code
applications within AppSheet.
By abstracting data
and services as APIs,
and using these APIs to build
applications without coding,
organizations can accelerate
development timelines
considerably, and reduce
their application backlogs.
Now it's your turn
to try it out and get
started by clicking the links
in the description below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]